والى جانب تفجير سد كخوفك وانابيب
الامونيا لا يزال الحديث متواصلا بخصوص
الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني المرتقب هجوم
تسعى موسكو جاهده الى ايقافه او تعطيله
نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
تحدث عن الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني حيث قال
ان موسكو لن تتفاجا في حال تم الهجوم لكن
الذي اشتهر برسائله التهديديه منذ بدايه
العمليه العسكريه حذر في الوقت نفسه من ما
غبت الاستهانه بالجيش الاوكراني سيما في
ظل توفره على اسلحه متطوره وبعيدا عن
الهجوم المضاد صعد من لهجته بشكل واضح
ودعا الى الاطاحه الكامله بالنظام النازي
في كييف على حد وصفه
وهذا الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني لا يزال
يشغل بال الجميع في اوكرانيا وسط تضارب
للانباء حول موعد تنفيذه فبينما تؤكل
موسكو بان الهجوم قد بدا بالفعل لا تزال
كياب تنفيذ ذلك نفي ينجا مره اخرى على
لسان اوليكسي دانيلوف ميني مجلس الامن
القومي والدفاع الاوكراني والذي قال لان
الهجوم المضاده الاوكراني لم يبدا بعد قال
ايضا ان الموضوع بيد الجيش الاوكراني
مشيرا الى ان الجميع سوف يعرف موعد الهجوم
المضاد عند بدايته
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات